ouais le boulot tout s'arrache tous à la
chaussée 1 alors vers le bourg et la
force
monsieur matte et mécontent de sa
nouvelle isolation réalisé il y à peine
un nom il sollicite aujourd'hui la vie
d'un artisan vous êtes sur un isolant
qui est pas adapté du tout c'est à dire
que c'est étonnant là est prévu paul
isation souvent pont au dessus du mur
mais pas de plancher pour cette
isolation de garage l'entreprise a
facturé 1925 euros mais monsieur et le
match n'a payé qu'un euro moi j'entends
pays et peut-être allée du mozart du bon
travail de fait voilà même si on donne
un semblant de zéro voilà vaut d'être à
nouveau travail pas un bon professionnel
mais là c'est pas des professionnels
mais moi j'aurais mieux fait que ça des
travaux avec ses revenus modestes ce
vésulien à bénéficier de la fameuse
isolation à 1 euro l'entreprise qui a
effectué les travaux s'est fait payer le
reste par des fournisseurs d'énergie
yannick perrin constate aujourd'hui les
malfaçons au titre d'une association
d'artisans du bâtiment chez la voisine
c'est carrément dangereux l'isolant est
en contact directement avec le corps de
cheminée ce qui est ce que de provoquer
un incendie
ce qui a déjà été le cas de figure sur
une maison aux frais de sa maman ils
forment tout seul tout ça se foutent de
ma gueule se coucher moi je n 1 mondial
et marc tout le monde qui fait chez moi
nous avons contacté la société le numéro
n'est plus attribué dans leurs bureaux
de vesoul
les membres de la capeb ont déjà
répertorié une cinquantaine de cas de
malfaçons en haute-saône cd photos cdml
ces informations qu'on récupère et puis
c'est ensuite de constituer un dossier
de compiler tout ça est de pouvoir
interpeller les élus nous parlementaires
locaux et c'est possible d'aller au delà
des parlementaires le gouvernement etc
etc
l'objectif de cette démarche est que les
pouvoirs publics se rendent compte de la
défaillance d'un dispositif sans
contrôle